okay
i'll go ahead and um start now seems
like
people are here already hi everyone uh
i'm carlos giacometti i work for voltham
research and today i will talk about
audio fingerprinting so the talk is
divided in a few sections
first i will try to explain what is
audio fingerprinting
why it is interesting what it can teach
us and how we can achieve it
and then i will present a couple of
different arguments
one quick note uh that i wanted to make
here is
both of these algorithms are somehow
dated
um they both come from
the around 2010
2015. um
however i chose to present these ones
because they are very informative and
interesting on
how the internals of the process of
fingerprinting
work um so i'll just go ahead
and start on what fingerprinting all
your fingerprinting
is and why it is difficult for the
machine
so all your fingerprinting is the task
of recognizing
recurring um and this is reasonably easy
for a human right
so here i have three signal uh three
signals
the original one which is this one by
a sly and failstone
[Music]
a compressed version that is just the
original one
saved as an mp3
it sounds pretty crappy but still very
recognizable
and then a corrupted version i took the
original song
played it to my laptop speakers and
recorded
with a laptop microphone
there is a delay it sounds really bad
all right but it is pretty evident to i
assume all of us
that these are the same song
however if we look at it like machine
we just look at the data underlying this
these audio objects these are quite
different here i'm trimming
one second bit from the compressed
version
and the original version and looking at
the difference between those and we can
see that this difference is definitely
not
zero um so
how to how to teach a machine
how to figure out these are
the same uh the same song so we need to
extract some feature
that is independent or very robust at
least
to the corruption of our signal waveform
is not great as we've seen
just a compression operation you can see
that the difference is definitely
different than zero
so there is a no-go already
we are not even talking about corruption
here just compressing it and saving it
as mp3
destroys the the waveform in a dramatic
way
so a starting point would be a mixed
time and frequency representation
um while the absolute values of it
can still be affected by compression and
corruption
the shapes and the features should be
relatively robust at least from an in
image processing point of view and
involved from language the computation
of
time frequency features is achieved by
the short time free transform family of
functions so
these are some examples i will show you
here the spectrogram
for the three signals that we listen
there
and you can see sure they are different
but the kind of shapes that are in the
value signals
are kind of solid um
so we will use this our as our starting
point
um and what is the starting point well
uh it is a short time fourier transform
which consists very simply
into partitioning the waveform into
blocks
and applying the fourier transform on
each of them
um so here we go we have this is one
such representation
this is adjusted a giant array and each
point at coordinate i and j
will represent the energy of the signal
at time i
and frequency j so we will use this as
starting point to handcraft a set of
features that are robust
to compression and corruption
um we will then compute
a set of fingerprints for each entry in
a database of songs and matching unknown
songs
to uh well hopefully mash and unknown
songs today
and entering the database so the first
algorithm that i want to talk about
is the kernel print algorithm this is
used
in services and applications like music
brains
and acoustic id for example
and this is common in many open source
applications one example that uses
acoustide and musicbrainz
is the vlc video player which
maybe some of you have used
so the algorithm itself is not
overly complicated there's a
pre-processing step
the spectrum is computer as we've seen
and then the whole thing is centered
around the computation
of these comma features it's just a
derivative of
something that is derived from the
spectrogram i will go in more detail in
the next few slides
and there are a couple of uh filtering
passes over these features um
a dramatic filter pass over the result
and then a compression
operation that will allow us to reduce
the amount of data that is produced
in a very dramatic way
so let's start what are these chroma
features
well um they are the answer to a very
simple question so you you
are listening to a signal and you want
to know
which notes are being played at each
time
so one small
detail i need to clarify is when i say
node i really mean
that the information about the octave in
which the
node is being played is being forgotten
so if i play
for example an a in the middle of the
keyboard or an a
at the top of the keyboard um those will
both be
classified as a so the absolute
octave of the node is is relevant for
this computation
so the starting point is we need to
construct a mapping between
the bin index of a spectrogram to a
frequency and then
the frequency is then mapped to an
absolute node
and and this plot here is an example of
such mapping
we can see for example that uh
bin number 100 will have a note
that is corresponding to an index of two
we don't care about what the node is if
it is an a
or if there's a d sharp or whatever we
just want to
have a a set of unique 12 unique
identifiers and using this mapping we
can create
a list of coefficients that we will then
use to filter the spectrogram
and this is a plot of all of our 12
filters and this is the plot of a single
filter
you can see the energy of each bin
in this interval will be ignored and
then the
energy of the bins
in this interval and this interval and
this interval will all be summed
together
so hopefully we'll get information about
which nodes is played at what time
so given this knowledge we can put all
of the pieces together
and compute the karma features i am
using
um our original
audio signal
our slide family stone uh so
you can see that this is a pretty
minimal implementation
that is a sampling step and then
a filter bank preparation which are the
filters that we saw in the previous
slide
slide a spectrogram computation
and then we just take the dot product
between the spectrogram
and the filter bank and what we obtain
is a sequence of vectors of length 12.
we can visualize you can see the x-axis
is time the y-axis
is our node index
then we can the next step is some
time axis filtering you can see here
our signal is convolved with this simple
triangular
kernel
so everything is spread out along the
time axis
and finally we normalize each
time slice
you can see here there is the high lower
intensity now
have intensity that is comparable
to all of the other
[Music]
to all of the other times so this is our
starting point this is our chroma
features
as a function of time the next step
is feature summarization and compression
first of all the array that you just saw
is partitioned
into blocks of length 16. and here we go
and this is the result
you just get a sequence of arrays of 12
by 16 elements
and a collection of 16
preset filters is computed and here the
colors are black for
uh mine for -1 white for one
and gray for zero and each filter
is then multiplied to for to each
of our partitions um
these are funny shapes um the shapes and
parameters for the filters were
optimized
using machine learning algo by the
author of the algorithm
and they were optimized over a large
data set
so each of the windows each of the
blocks is passed through
all of the filters so
each multiplication produces a single
number so for each time
stamp we obtain 16
real numbers we can
visualize those again in the same way
time access index that this time instead
of
1 to 12 goes from 1 to 16.
so we want to compress this information
so what we can do is take
all of the numbers in each single vector
and quantize them
into four values and map them to grey
code
which just means i i i take
a number that is that i can represent it
in
just two bits of information
so the quantization step the parameters
for the quantization were also optimized
by
uh the paper the author of the algorithm
and you can see
uh the jumps in quantization
are uh kind of odd and definitely not at
uh particularly uh around numbers or
anything as i said these were optimized
uh and are unique to each filter so from
a sequence of vectors of
16 real numbers we get a sequence of
vectors of 16
integers each bound between
0 and 3. so we can compute those
so this real numbers get transformed
into quantized numbers between 0 and 3
and as i said before
each of these integers can be
represented by just two bits
so all of the 16 compressed
representations can be joined together
to produce
a single 32-bit integer so for example
this
vector of 16 uh integer from 0 to 3
that's compressed in a single 32 32-bit
unsigned integer
so in the end we get a sequence of
32-bit integers and and this is our
fingerprint and we have a nice data
structure involved in language
and we can stuff it into a numeric array
of type inside integer 32
and we can visualize it by plotting the
bit representation of all the
integers again time axis
and bit index and each value obviously
can be 0
1 black or white
so now we need to test this algorithm
against the different signals here i
have the original signal
our compressed signal corrupted signal
and a completely different signal and i
compute the chroma print
of each of these signals
so a good way of comparing fingerprints
is to compute the average bit error
[Music]
and you can see the average bit error
between the original and the contrast
version
is very low and we can also visualize
the difference as a
function of time you can see the
difference between the original and the
compressed version produces
a very sparse constellation
instead if we look at two completely
different signals you can see the
average
is much higher and the
bit by bit difference becomes much much
noisier so
essentially what we have obtained is um
a fingerprint that is extremely robust
to
compression and resampling those kind of
operation have a really minimal effect
on the fingerprint
however if we compare the original
signal to a corrupted version of itself
then the situation is not as rosy
we can perform this comparison by
measuring the average bit error of
the between the original signal and
a time shifted version of the corrupted
signal and we can move this time shift
and see where the minimal error is to
optimize the alignment and you can see
that the minimal
error here is
large i would say i am not sure that we
would be able to say that this
is as a match um
so um this algorithm is very good for
compression but corruption
uh kind of destroys um the fingerprint
in a
pretty unsatisfactory way um and
if you want some references they have
listed here and by the way the notebook
and some supporting
file are uploaded
on the presentation page
so the next algorithm that i want to
talk about
is the algorithm popularized by shazam
[Music]
and i am not aware of a name
for the sagran i will call it the
constellation method
because of and it will become clear in
the next few slides why
this name makes sense this is based
on the relationship between peaks found
in the
spectrogun again the algor itself
doesn't seem too daunting you compute
the spectrogram
you find the peaks in it and then build
these
constellations which have nothing more
than groupings
of peaks and then hush the information
that you gained
building these constellations so let's
get into it
again the starting point is a
spectrogram
that i will visualize here as an image
and again i am starting with the same
signal
that we were looking at before
the peak finding operation is a
straightforward image processing
operation
as simply a deletion step
followed by a subtraction between the
delayed image and the original one
this leaves us with a nice map of
peaks in the spectrogram however we want
to make sure that
peaks with a smaller amplitude are
ignored
so then the result is filtered again by
peak amplitude
and as you can see many of the peaks
disappearing
in this separation so from this image we
can
extract the position of each peaks um
the x-coordinate is the time index and
the y-coordinate
is the frequency index we don't really
care about
an absolute value of time in seconds and
an absolute value in frequency
of frequency in hertz we just care about
indexing you know these points in a
unique and repeatable way and we can
visualize all of these points on top of
the original spectrogram
obviously there are parameters that one
can tweak in the algorithm for example
this maximum
empty amplitude um
that here we are setting it to this
arbitrary value to
have a result with more or less peaks
so if we just use the absolute position
of the peaks
and just identified it with
the absolute time and absolute frequency
we would end up with an extremely
brittle fingerprint
since any kind of corruption of
compression will obliterate any number
of peaks and
even a small time shift would make
the absolute time indexing of the peaks
absolutely useless
in addition to that if we forget the
time information
just the frequency information well we
are
more than guaranteed each single peak
can or will appear in any number of
different regular links
so the proposed solution
is to group um our peaks into
constellations
uh and constellations is just a fancy
way of saying
just a set of uh
more than one point um so each of these
groups as each of these constellations
is formed by
one anchor point and a set of targets um
and here as you can see i'm just using
block map to
group this in an easy way so what we
what information do we store for each
constellation well
we stir uh per each pair
um anchored to target we stay we
stir the absolute frequencies
and the relative time difference so we
stir some
relative information um between the
peaks
we do not stir any absolute time
so what what we achieve with the
separation
is make the information that we stir
significantly uh more unique to the
actual requiring
even if this specific peak happens in
many
recordings the fact that this peak is
followed by this
other set of peaks is more and more
unique to the recording that we are
considering
um and we can visualize um the result
on top of the original spectrogram
so once we have our collection of
constellations
what we need to do is efficiently stir
them
the parameters that we have chosen mean
that
we have a reasonably small set of
constellations
i think is like about some tens of
thousands of constellations per signal
on average
um for sure
if you want to make a finger painting a
bit more robust
you can for example
decrease the amplitude threshold or you
can
increase the number of targets in in
this case
as you can see here i'm just choosing
constellations of five
five points but you could choose to stir
a bigger set of targets and this will
combinatorially increase the number of
constellations that are still so to
compress this at least a little bit
or to make them unique we hash
the frequency of the anchor the
frequency of the target
and as we were saying before the
relative time difference between
the anchor and the target
and as an ancillary bit of information
we also stir
the absolute time um of
the anchor we will not use this in the
matching process the utility of this
will
become apparent um in the next
few steps but again the the piece of
information
that will be used for the matching is
this hash again
frequency other frequency relative time
difference
and this is how one random constellation
looks like
we can restore this and in a byte right
this could be
a string whatever whatever way your
database will be
the happiest with stirring it
so we have
a solid algorithm to compute
fingerprints so we can just apply that
on a small collection of varied
recurrings here
i i just selected a random
subset of recordings i have on my hard
drive
they value across multiple genres
this is just a random sample of it
[Music]
we map our constellation function
over all of the audio signals by the way
the code that is being used is
contained in one of the files uploaded
it is not meant to be efficient it is
meant to be
um explanatory so
don't plan to use this for large
deficits unless you are planning to
uh um give it a lot of time to compute
uh it can be made much much more
efficient
um but that was just not the goal of
this talk
um okay so we have
uh hashed all of our collection
and when we apply the same function to
our corrupted signal
the one that sounded terrible let's
listen to
to it again was recorded with the laptop
uh microphone there is definitely a time
shift so
it is kind of problematic occurring
so the simplest way to verify a match is
to compute the wrong number of equal
hashes and
this is what the simple um this simple
bit of code does and again here i am
only considering the hashes that
absolute time
information that i am i stirred before
is completely ignored
and then i am plotting the result
this is just the entering the database
and the absolute number of matches and
you can see that
there is a clear winner here that is
above clearly above the average which is
the correct result
however if my recording was even
noisier or if i had a significantly
bigger
database with things that were possibly
much more similar
interpreting the information about the
wrong number of matches
might not be enough in all cases
so one potential solution
so one issue one cause of that issue was
if two different songs had a similar
amount of
matching constellations however these
constellations would happen
at very different absolute times
in the song to solve the problem
we finally can use those absolute times
that we stir
in our collection so to start we select
a few candidates
uh and we serve them by number of
matches and in this
in this simple example we just get
deferred candidates with the the most
matches
um and then perich matching hash hi
we collect the absolute timestamps
ti both in the test and the original
track
this is what this bit of code here does
and you can see the reach
of our values we get these pairs right
this is the time stamp in the original
this is the timestamp
in the corrupt in the in the one that we
are testing etc etc
and the assumption that we make is that
um
even if there is a an offset the truck
plays at the same speed as the original
one so all of the collected
timestamps if we plot them uh timestamp
in the original versus timestamp
in the corrupted one it should still
form a straight line if it's not the
same
recording we should see a reasonably
random distribution of points and we can
see here
this assumption is completely verified
by
the data that we have here you can see
all the uh time stamps like on a single
line
doesn't need to and in fact it doesn't
go through the origin because there is
an offset between our corrupted
time offset between our corrupted
version and the original one
all the other ones are randomly
distributed there aren't very many so i
guess
the extent the randomness cannot be
verified as much
but they definitely do not lie in a
single line
so this provides us a robust algorithm
that unlike the chromoprint one is very
solid
to heavy corruption including time
shifting
and here are some references if you want
to look at details
um other possibilities that i want to
just briefly mention
uh one paper that has been published a
few years ago
is proposes to do a similar thing to
the shazam the constellation argument
but instead of using
peaks detected in the image it proposes
to use
orb descriptors from the spectrum image
and you can very easily extract those
in the wolfram language by just using
the image keypoints
um with the method or b option
um the rest of the algorithm essentially
is
kind of similar you produce some kind of
hash starting from
these points
of course neural networks are
always a good candidate however they
they are a black box right um
if something goes wrong you cannot go
back and identify
the exact peak that caused the um
[Music]
um corruption of the signal
so obviously you can very easily train
something
um to to provide this kind of service
we don't have any pre-trained network
that does that however we do have a
reasonably robust feature extractor
network in the net repository um and we
can do
a kind of a zero-order approximation of
what neural network that does this
job would be you can see we can compute
some kind of fingerprint based on data
if we search for exact matches we
obviously do not find any because
this was not trained with that purpose
in mind
if we do something slightly better by
measuring the working distance between
the corrupted features and the original
ones we can see
that the correct
[Music]
sample is extracted however this is
definitely not
a robust operation mainly because
this network was not trained with the
goal of fingerprinting so the results
are pretty
underwhelming i could easily imagine
training
an autoencoder network would be pretty
solid or
just fine tuning this net model that we
have
in the repository either with an
autoencoder task or with a
feature with an embedding optimization
where each class is represented by the
original recording
and several variation of corruption of
the original requirement
anyways i think this is all i wanted to
present today i hope you enjoy the talk
and if you have any questions um
make sure to shoot them in the chat
on possible
yes the shazam uh algorithm you can
definitely do that and in fact
the um example that i present
doesn't present doesn't use the whole
the whole audio signal of the corrupted
recording
is just 30 seconds but you could very
easily
look at portions of the
test signal i could trim this to 10
second
verify the number of matches if it
doesn't
uh produce any results record for a bit
more
etc etc so yes that is completely
compatible
with the the functions that i presented
here
let me know if you have any other
questions either throw them
into well no yes
i think the possible chart is
the main way to go yeah again i chose to
present some dated classic arguments
mainly because they are very
instructional it is very easy to
understand
what is going on step by step and how
and why the algorithm works however
compared to neural networks
there you just have a black box that
does something based on the training so
hopefully this
gave some insight on how the audio
fingerprinting operation
works and why it can work and why it
might not work and why it might fail
okay and i guess if there are no further
questions
i will stop sharing and we can close
this meeting
thank you everyone very much for
attending